on serait sûrement d'accord avec madame
mais sur cette urgence d'agir pour
réduire les gaz à effet de serre nicolas
hulot est l'ambassadeur mondial du
climat nommé par le président français
françois hollande c'est lui entre autres
qui va piloter cette grande conférence
de paris qui débute le 30 novembre et
alexandra vous avez interviewé monsieur
loïc part notamment de la responsabilité
des pays industrialisés à s'impliquer là
pour le climat et oui nicole nicolas
hulot c'est cet animateur vous vous
souvenez sans doute ces lignes de la
fameuse émission sayah qui s'est passé
un peu partout dans le monde c'est un
homme qui est très engagée dans les
questions du climat et maintenant il est
devenu une sorte de nonce apostolique
pour le monde entier de françois
hollande pour amener les pays à signer
une entente sur la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre avant que la conférence
commence alors il se promène partout
dans le monde
il est venu au canada et malheureusement
ici il n'a pas été reçue au plus haut
niveau de l'état comme c'est le cas dans
d'autres pays
par contre il a un message très précis
pour les canadiens il voudrait que le
canada redevienne le leader dans le
domaine de l'environnement
je crois pas qu'on soit là pour
distribuer des bons et des mauvais
points
nous paierons north nîmes en au
renoncement nos petites lâchetés nos
petites et pau crazy ou au contraire
nous bénéficierons tous le canada la
france le japon l'australie de notre
intelligence et notre ambition
collective
non mais comme ne le sont pas la plupart
pour l'instant des engagements contenus
et la situation mais ce n'est pas une
critique à nominem sur le canada c'est
que je pense qu'il est de l'intérêt du
canada comme de l'union européenne d'en
faire le maximum parce que les
conséquences géopolitiques vont être
tiré les conséquences humaines vont être
terribles
c'est quelque part l'avenir de
l'humanité qui est en cause mais le
canard ac est un grand pays qui jouent
un rôle très important et qui peut donc
dont l' influence et l'engagement pour
être contagieux a une capacité à se
diversifier sur un plan énergétique et
économique
oui le rôle du canada est essentiel donc
plus le canada en fera plus tard un
mouvement l'entraînement vis-à-vis des
autres piques
les pays du g20 pour ne parler que de
cela 15 pays au g20 représentent 70 %
des émissions de gaz à effet c'est à ben
moi je m'adresse prioritairement à ces
pays là ils détiennent eux les clés du
succès ou de l'échec de paris
ça vaut pour ses 15 pays voilà donc ya
pas à pointer du doigt tel ou tel pays
mais il ya simplement a appelé à la
responsabilité historique puisque c'est
la grande histoire qui se joue à paris
ses 15 pays qui représentent 70 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
personne ne peut ignorer la réalité
énergétique économique du canada et on
peut pas en faire abstraction
donc l'intérêt du canada comme l'intérêt
l'union européenne comme l'intérêt tous
les pays c'est d'anticiper essaie de se
diversifier et je pense que justement le
canada qui me semble-t-il sur un plan
économique a peut-être plus de marge de
manoeuvre pour se diversifier c'est
d'anticiper c'est aussi son intérêt
purement économique d'anticiper le fait
que à un moment ou un autre nous allons
sortir des énergies fossiles
c'est inéluctable c'est surtout un
message qui est envoyé aux pays qui
souffre des changements climatiques qui
n'est pas compréhensible d'un grand pays
comme le canada c'est ça envoie
évidemment un message de désengagement
voilà même si probablement que ça n'est
pas le message que le canada souhaite
envoyer c'est la manière dont ce message
est reçu
c'est un enjeu qui doit dépasser nos
petits clivages habituels le canada qui
est un pays ami que les français
notamment adore que le monde adore on
compte sur lui et donc moi je ne me
résigne pas je compte sur le canada et
je ne doute pas que le canada à un
moment un autre va revenir dans le
leadership sur ces sujets là
la conférence de paris son succès ne se
fera pas sur les promesses elle se fera
sur les moyens dont les états vont se
doter pour honorer ses promesses
les mots ne suffiront plus à paris